so i saw a [ __ ] gray man
uh the other day gray man
which is uh
you know it's i gotta say man
i i want to say this ryan gosling is a
captivating act i mean he is a good
actor that dude is good yes does he
sometimes wait too long to say something
yes but is that good acting yes
right
take your time be patient if you do
acting classes they say be patient you
don't have to
just because you're mad you don't have
to be patient so ryan gosling takes that
i mean you're probably in a waiting room
with him at this point when he's acting
they'll be like how are you and he's
just like
i'm good and you're just like
you just that was i had to watch you act
for 11 seconds before you said that you
know but he's good he's captivating
right at least he's watchable he's like
got that denzel thing where you're just
like okay i'm watching him and it's cool
and i see behind his face a little bit
and so the first i don't know 20 minutes
of the movie it's kind of just him doing
[ __ ] and you're just like i could kind
of watch him just kind of walk around i
don't even need to he could be i i don't
[ __ ] it doesn't matter really what's
happening if he's on the screen because
he's just you know what he's doing dude
without even knowing it he's massaging
the lens isn't he
that's what he's doing dude he took the
[ __ ] camera to burke williams that's
what he does right
that's what he does dude he's got a gift
certificate to burke williams and he's
bringing the camera
right he's massaging the lens that's
what he's doing dude
and he does that and like they find out
you know he's one of those movies i'm
not going to spoil it but it's one of
those movies where like the people in
the movie are like uh
numbers you know
[Laughter]
it's like yeah we gotta talk to number
five uh yeah he double-crossed us ah
[ __ ] number eight uh number two
double-crossed us so that's why he's
whacked and we can't seem to find number
three he went m.i.a in turkey
you're like all right you know and then
you gotta like not only it's hard enough
for me to know whose people who people
are in movies anyway and now i gotta
like keep track of what [ __ ] number
they are yeah number six went [ __ ]
rogue one of them always went rogue
and you're just like all right okay so
five so which one is and you're like
wait
ryan gosling is full
six
okay and he just killed four and then
the five is the okay
and then they're like
well we're not going to give the job to
five are we and then you find out are
you like oh [ __ ] okay and then you find
out that chris evans is five and he's a
[ __ ] mustache he has a mustache and
my whole thing with chris evans is dude
i know these are the guys that directed
captain america which is [ __ ] great
and i know i guarantee it they were like
we got to give you a mustache we don't
want you to be captain america-e and the
way chris evans
acts in this movie dude
since he has a mustache
he might as well twirl it with his
fingers
i mean dude the guy is having a [ __ ]
smorgasbord dude
i mean he is
he has got
[ __ ] courses and he's just eaten the
[ __ ] out of this scenes
and dude you might as well be [ __ ]
is that what we think mr ryan gosling
unbelievable dude
it's unbelievable and then ryan gosling
is in there waiting to act because chris
evans is doing all the twirling mustache
and shits
and then there's like and and anytime
ryan gosling or billy uh bob thornton is
not on it
i'm just like dude i'm out dude because
billy bob thornton is one of those other
guys that doesn't need to do much that's
[ __ ] good but dude they got the guy
from bridgerton in it
and then this other chick in it and it's
like whenever they're in the [ __ ]
scene i'm like can we
you know
or the [ __ ] uh
there's another actor in it and it's oh
the ana de armas girl who's who's been
good
uh before you know um i'm i'm a uh you
know
dude they don't want me to get in one of
those [ __ ] movies i swear to god oh i
swear to [ __ ] christ dude if i get in
one of those [ __ ] movies and they
happen to not cut me out of it
bro
johnny [ __ ] steals the scene i swear
i'm going home with that movie dude you
put me in a [ __ ] part
i'm going
i'll play what i'm going home with that
[ __ ] i show up the first day i bring a
suitcase they say what are you doing i
start putting props in it they say what
are you doing we need those for the
movie i say that's too bad i'm going
home with this one
what do you want me to do you want me to
play british
i'm going home with this [ __ ]
you want me to play
is it
i'm going home with it dude
and i don't even [ __ ] do i'm not and
i don't do it racist either like you
genuinely feel me japanese by the middle
of the movie you're like i actually
forgot chris alia was in it dude did he
get shorter for this part
i swear to god dude maybe i dye my hair
a little bit it gets a little bit black
or even though calvin says my hair is
black it's not as brown
but maybe i'll straighten it you know
not many japanese people out there with
wavy hair let's face it
i don't say much to it and i do that 11
second acting that [ __ ] ryan rent or
ryan golovky does what's his name ryan
gosling does
and i [ __ ] straight up
depends how far back you want to go
into the past
just
packing it up packing up the scene i'll
pack up the scene dude i swear to god
you want to put me in your movie you
will get a [ __ ] bang for your buck
dude
[Laughter]
um
yeah but the movie is just like
there's one it's it's so it's just like
you know
i don't know
anytime directors it's like brothers
it's like just one of you guys do it
like what the [ __ ]
so
you know
that's like so the the thing about a
director is you gotta know your [ __ ]
so well
and you gotta be like nah this is how
we're doing it to have two people do it
it's like okay well then i already like
don't trust it
but there's one there's one scene that's
like the biggest set piece scene like
it's like 20 minutes and it's like ryan
gosling is [ __ ] uh handcuffed to a
park bench and like a million guys are
trying to [ __ ] shoot him and and they
can't for some reason
and
the whole thing is chris evans is trying
to kill him
the whole movie but in this set piece
he's behind he's in another location in
in uh with a bunch of tvs looking at
every monitor
and telling everyone to kill him and and
they're trying to kill him and they
can't
and and chris evans is just in the
building like
hakka come on you can't shoot this guy
get him where is he there go get him and
he's like number number 14 get him get
on there he's behind the bench and it's
like
have him be there
have them be there
the whole movie is it's spy versus spy
and one spies tucked away behind some
[ __ ]
tv screens
have them be there
just twirling his mustache
he's got movies on one of the [ __ ] tv
oh great that guy died we gotta get he's
calling back up that's what he's doing
dude you gotta have the guy there
anyway dude it's fine the movie's fine i
don't know
ryan gosling's so good
he really is
and i would i would trust me dude
i would tell you if he wasn't
hey hollywood
sup
crazy
crazy
[Music]
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]